TR
et ici au pied du château de la
Madeleine on vous forme à l'art de la
guerre Viking pendant 2 jours une
reconstitution historique a permis aux
10000 visiteurs présents de découvrir
leur mode de vie au 9e siècle les
Vikings sont passé dans les Yvelines il
y avait plusieurs camp Vikings qui
étaient sur les îles des bordde scenes
lorsqu'ils ont attaqué Paris au 9e
siècle donc c'est bien antérieur à la
période du château de la Madeleine mais
c'est une thématique qui est assez
porteuse qui plaît à beaucoup c'est
hyper important parce que bah du coup ça
représente aussi l'histoire comprendre
aussi comment on vivait à l'époque par
qu'on est aussi dans une génération
aujourd'hui où les
enfants n'ont pas forcément notion de
tout ce qui est quotidien donc c'est
aussi important de de transmettre au
jeunes générations une autre époque et
une autre vie dans ce campement plus
vraque nature une vingtaine de bénévoles
incarné la vie du camp ils étaient
présents afin de montrer le savoir-faire
des Scandinaves aux ivelinois chacun on
leur par particularité donc de base nous
représentons bah la vie en général donc
la vie de camp selon les envies et les
capacités de chacun choisissent de faire
do soit de représenter le combat ce qui
faisait partie de leur vie aussi et et
des artisanats l'occasion de découvrir
l'ancêtre du tricot écouter les compes
des hommes du Nord ou venir s'essayer à
des jeux de stratégie j'adore tout ce
qui est époque médiévale et
particulièrement Viking que ça soit
histoire ou mythologie et c'est un bel
endroit en plus il fait beau et il y a
plein de gens passionnés et passionnant
C association Marle portaine le clan
Divar s'appuie sur des recherches
historiques pour proposer une expérience
immersive notre souhait c'était de faire
de la médiation culturelle autour de
l'époque donc autour du peuple
scandinave de l'air Viking c'est
extrêmement important puisque c'est
l'occasion pour nous de mettre en valeur
notre patrimoine de l'ouvrir au plus
grand nombre et de proposer des
animations qui peuvent toucher tous nos
publics le château de la Madeleine
proposera une nouvelle programmation
avec d'autresonstitutions historiques
sur des weekends dans les prochains mois
les dates ne sont pas encore
communiquées